remember I'm just sticking it in and
then just testing wait you did that at a
restaurant no no no oh we did at Joe's
house okay if you don't suck good
sometimes you get like pieces of the
outside voice turn there yeah did you
guys hear about the salon owner who got
arrested and she faced seven days in
jail because she defied the stay at home
orders and she actually opened up her
salon and said look ya'll work cutting
hair it has a good y'all y'all really
stasis in Texas in the city of Dallas I
don't know what the law for businesses
yeah yeah for businesses and so she did
receive a cease and desist letter and
she actually ripped it up in public as
like a protest and said we have a right
to state to remain open well she's
endangering the pump of it yeah that's
how the officials see it yeah but for
her she sees it I was like a violation
of the Constitution her constitutional
right I got the right to get everybody
sick goddammit yeah I mean to the point
where she gets a resident to all of it's
part of the protest right yeah looting
the park getting arrested [ __ ] you got
me arrested to make a point American
rock to get everybody sick if I want to
and so now she's no martyr for the
movement no a lot of the people cuz I
started looking into like responses to
this whole situation and a lot of people
have her back and what they're saying is
that us as a entire country and globally
we're getting conditioned into thinking
that by standing up for your freedom
you're being selfish and that everyone
has their own rights to take care of
their health and the government should
not be involved in in like forcing us
and like forcing us to protect our
health if the way they're seeing it I
mean that is I already don't like people
are dealing with obesity they're doing
everything in their cause but I think
we're like a pandemic like this and to
have crazy measures that we have to go
into I think that was like all of his
hands no ways but to deal with it like
every other country in the world was
dealing with it like we're kind of like
one of the last to follow that you know
that's what the medical professionals
are saying where they're saying before
this pandemic
pandemic which is obesity right yeah so
if if obesity is already it and we don't
have a national public health law where
it's like let's take all sodas and ban
sodas why are we doing why are we having
what we so extreme there were some I
think it's also you doing it to yourself
then lacking it you sick and you can get
died from it yeah that's a problem not
catching my fat you know yeah it's okay
I wish I do at that point a lot like a
lot of these people that are arguing
that side of like well you know what
what a deem just said where it's like I
can get you sick and that's like not
your fault kind of think it a lot of
these people are thinking it is your
fault because you should be taking your
own precautions to not get sick by
others I think it's funny in like and
there is people like that well there's
also a [ __ ] tuna dump people so maybe I
get her side because I saw her testimony
being like I I need to provide for my
family we don't have money for food who
are you guys gonna help me with yeah but
it's kind of like um like when doctors
failed as the doctor came on like Fox
News and he was talking about how people
drown in pools all the time and how can
we not force enforcing things are around
that mister cuz cuz I cuz pools aren't
just randomly appearing in places for
people to drown in that's not doesn't
make any sense to like compare the two
and they're saying because it was
another thing about like cars and stuff
like oh people myth movies people die
from car accidents but then they're like
what we actually take precautions we we
have to wear simple now you have to you
can't use your phone your thing is
people enforcing it
you gotta get a driver's license yeah
there's all of these things that are
happening and from then there's wait
wait wait wait less car accidents now oh
but there's obviously people that do
crazy stuff people that live in
regulations on the car being built
differently like they have to collapse
now because during wheels held to many
people and in the main difference though
here is that the crown of ours is it's
not known I mean I
we still barely know anything about it
and then there's no cure and it's
invisible to our eyes you know I mean
like a lot of the other things you guys
are talking about it seems like their
solutions are right there in front of us
no but people still fight against that -
right people like right people hate
helmet laws from motorcycle
depending on what state you're in you
know right no seatbelt laws and
depending on what state you're in but
that's but there's no protest against
not wearing helmets people purposely
move out of California to ride their
bike another right in the fighting
there's the solution for that back
difference between this and in the hope
coronavirus thing though is that I don't
think that people understand that there
is no fix you know yeah so I think the
arguments are kind of like I don't know
like goes nowhere at this point yeah I
seen that one doctor that was like
giving a speech at like the Riverside
County Hospital or something so he was
obviously super Republican Riverside
County
but he was saying that like don't
believe the experts they're all aligned
to you we all not all doctors agree or
whatever so it's just crazy to hear like
so much mixed messaging that like it's
hard to know what to really believe if
it's bad or if it's not that bad I think
that might be the one I got it - yeah I
think he ended up getting the doctor
yeah there are people that is my Roni
anyone that's kind of questioning the
statistics or challenging it or whatever
they're there immediately being shut
down and that's a conspiracy in itself
because people should be I know there's
a doctor in Bakersfield and he came out
and news saying like yeah we ran a study
within our patients in our hospital and
it's extremely low and a fatality like
is extremely low in our County so
specifically our County should open up
because you know within their sample
group in their city it's completely
different from LA or any of these other
cities but then they got a huge like
backlash from all these different
responsible yeah it doesn't make any
sense cuz they're not a walled-off City
exactly like it would only make sense if
nobody could go in or out it's like oh
yeah you guys can do whatever you want
yeah if it's like an island like in
Hawaii or something and everyone that's
super at the islands quarantine exactly
and no one can leave the island and yeah
[ __ ] open it up a coin hunt how are
you gonna get it
and also like I feel like certain types
of information if you try to spread it
it has it could have potentially deadly
side effects right like if you if you
try to spread the fact that oh it's not
dangerous then people could take that
too far they're like alright let's just
[ __ ] around Hey and all of a sudden like
death spike right there's good arguments
on those Berryman it's like I actually
liked her argument which I still don't
agree with oh yeah let me show it but
I've seen also other people arguing with
protests and signs that I need a haircut
boogie board in Huntington Beach he had
the guy who wrote s ting at the
Huntington Beach one hero he's a boogie
board he was like let us boogie it's
like okay that your first press it was a
guy Huntington Beach and he was saying
remember the Jews were quarantined yeah
how can you even compare the two you
crazy [ __ ] talking about judge I would
like to say that I have much respect for
this course and a loss just worse yet
hold wait that I've never been been in
this position before and it's not some
place that I want to be a judge at home
I have to disagree with you sir when I
when you say that I'm selfish because
feeding my kids is not selfish I have
hair stylists that are going hungry
because they'd rather feed their kids so
sir if you think the law is more
important than kids getting fed then
please go ahead with your decision but I
am NOT going to shut this along you know
one part that the PPP law this is one of
the parts that I think that that's nice
that got all the pvp's waived more than
thousand bucks yeah she's a business
owner the government is [ __ ] up on is
um that makes people panic like this
yeah I understand where she's coming
from by disagree with her going back
into practice I understand where her
come worries to coming from because me
and Joey owned a company and like we
think about employees first and like how
people employed like feed their families
and all that so I get where she's coming
from right but I think the government
where it's kind of [ __ ] up it's they
first put in a policy that makes you
panic and then go oh yeah
here's how you guys can get help versus
here's the care act first this money is
already gonna be yours then you already
feel comfortable so you don't put people
in a position it's the order of things
yeah cuz if you're like yeah you shut
your business down at putting they put
you in siege pretty much you know oh
[ __ ] oh my god
I live months a month I don't have much
money and then they're like oh don't
worry we're gonna have a truck that's
gonna come full of apples no it's a
[ __ ] truck comedy when's the phone
truck coming it never comes versus not
just that but then the truck ends up
sending it to people who have already oh
[ __ ] ton of apples exactly but hey we
see this [ __ ] [ __ ] coming everyone
isn't just gonna get 200 bucks you're
gonna get this mounting money or
whatever and then that way can you guys
please shut down I think people would be
way more on board - c'mon okay quietly
feed my kids see that's bash the [ __ ]
we're like since the beginning you've
always kind of like Happy's like I'm
sure you know the conspiracy theories in
my head and the more it plays out the
more really feeds into my own conspiracy
I think it's manufactured chaos or
taking advantage of a situation and
prolonging it
there was definitely a nice little money
heist that was going down with I mean
Jeff bezels he let go of his own stocks
just to buy a right bag Zach at a lower
rate I'm the one winner out of this
whole situation these peoples they knew
that it was coming there was like nine
billionaires or something that traded
very like coincidentally at a certain
time in February yeah how is that how
are they not getting arrested cuz
they're all Donati loopholes and stuff
so I I just saw this video from an
economists perspective because right now
we're getting a lot of medical
perspective right so you don't really
hear at least most people aren't
listening to how this is gonna fit
affect us monetarily and what she was
claiming is that it's not really so much
the rich and the poor that's gonna be
[ __ ] but it's people in the middle the
small businesses you know people with
professional like jobs or whatever
because there's a lot of people that are
working retail or whatever they're
claiming unemployment and they're making
more than they did as whatever they were
doing before like they're getting 600
bucks a week or three grand a month or
whatever and they were probably making
like less than two thousand bucks a
month so they're making more on
unemployment
than they did before and on top of that
I don't even want to go back to work
yeah it's a it's a total [ __ ] but then
that's the point so Power Move of the
ridge going hey you guys you guys need
to do this with your hands out and go
ask for more let's keep them pacified
second while we loot it because what
people don't realize is if the money
went appropriately to the citizens of us
right it would have been 18,000 not
[ __ ] a couple grand a month because
this would be I think a forty thousand
per person oh yeah so they're paying us
a couple grand a month and we're happy
because it's a little bit more than what
we used to make so you're only looking
at it relatively to what you used to
make that's the [ __ ] money heist
right there and at the same time who's
getting all the money it's the top
people who were friends with the
government like the top businesses all
those guys these some of these companies
it's like same [ __ ] with 2008 all the
insurance companies all of them they got
it and then where do they go they went
on vacation with that money so I don't
know man I just think it's kind of
[ __ ] up because the small business is
they'll get the the PPP loan which is
like depending on how much you make or
whatever that's different from
unemployment and all that
it's a forgivable loan if you spend it
on employees and payroll it's forgivable
you're not to pay it back but here's the
problem
you gotta do it within eight weeks so if
you already let go all your employees
they have other jobs you don't have
anything as spent on it's just you have
all this extra money you don't know what
the [ __ ] to do with it right
another problem is two is so the same
money goes to both people right it's the
same money goes to the small businesses
and employees so they go okay cool here
business here's your PPP loan that you
have to spend on employees and they go
here here employees here's your
unemployment checks that you can only
get if you're not employed so it becomes
this tug-of-war so now the business the
business or I come back to work they're
like I don't want to work because I want
to pay you I want to pay you so we can
keep getting this money and I don't have
to pay it back and we can keep the
ecosystem going but these guys why would
I come back to work if imma leave me
paid this much when I have this much
money for not working so it's almost
like they do put the money up front
what the government is doing but it now
increases tug of war action instead of
like what's taking care of the whole
system maybe it's just because I'm a
positive person okay you guys always you
know it sounds like this big and scary
monster but for me it's just everybody's
trying everybody's trying their best
coming up with different solutions and
sometimes the solutions are
contradicting each other because they do
each other the complicated situation
they see two different problems a child
solve one a child solve the other but
then when they trance all the other one
it contradicts the other one and that's
just a yes I see it as hey here's a good
idea let's give these people $10,000 oh
but you know what you know be kind of
cool it's like hey I'll give it to you
because I know you first and then maybe
I'll go for my friends and then oh
whatever is leftover we could give it to
those strangers over there I think
that's what's happening I think it's a
complicated system yeah some people can
get to the front of line at first and I
don't know if it's as much shadow
dealing as it sounds like I personally
think it is you're like Stephen evidence
I feel like they well the evidence for
me
it feels more like people who have more
resources can get to the front because
of their resources and not because they
have a deep dark connection it might not
be a deep dark connection but if they
know each other
that's networking that's the privilege
that's the Oliver key that's right
it's like insider trading so they know
the people that are like hey everybody
government that's the lower that's
illegal because that's supposed to be
for the people it's supposed to be for
the greater good right nots it's like
hey maybe American Airlines should in
the head like [ __ ] I don't know 20
million or whatever they got maybe they
would have been okay with five or
whatever right but they got that big
amount so it's probably because they're
friends with the Fed and and to me it
doesn't have to be a huge conspiracy to
see the payouts I think more than half
went to financial institutions yeah and
we see this like on a super small level
so in a neighboring city we're friends
with a council member and in their
council that city's already jam-packed
ready
right and since there's all this new
China money coming in they're like hey
we can't I know right now the laws that
exist we can't have any hotels on this
street but if you guys can help change
it you guys will all get a cut from the
profits that happened our homie is the
only one that voted against it but
because everyone else likes money it was
like 4 to 1 or something so now on this
busiest street you see all these hotels
being erected and the homie is not gonna
get a single cut from that so I see that
or being honored yeah I mean that's what
lobbying exactly so yeah so it's not a
shadow government what its could
clearcoat it's a lot of just like broken
things but so I guess what I'm saying is
it's not so much that here's the Care
Act or here's the policy and then people
have connections they get to the front
it's the underwriting happens before it
even gets granted so if the work is pre
done already before they changed a lot
to have hotels on the street there is
this never did they already line
everything up and then okay cool and
then everyone else kind of gets the
scraps yeah guys that's how I see it
[Music]